hi i'm david alvarez i play bernardo in
west side story i'm paul taswell i was a
costume designer for west side story and
this is trade secrets
so paul uh how did you find yourself uh
working on west side story
well i uh
was approached by stephen to skype to
have a meeting i think that
i came onto his radar because of
hamilton maybe stephen asked to speak
with me and i found out that it was
about west side story and you know i was
you know
so excited then you know after i calmed
down
you know realized that
it was going to be a challenge but i was
up for the task from your perspective uh
what is the role of a costume designer
one of the things that you know that i
realized early on was that costumes the
work that i do
provides the first visual impact or you
know essence of character that an
audience will get you know whether it's
on film or television or a live
performance you know it it gives
the audience uh a glimpse into who this
character might be in the same way that
you know we make judgments about people
that are walking towards us on the
street you know if we come across
somebody that we don't know we make a
judgment about who they are if they're a
threat what kind of personality they
they have you know making choices about
costumes for characters it's important
that they
are specific to how you want to tell
their story because uh the audience is
going to you know
look at that as you know a clue into who
that character is
what what is one of the things that
uh people don't realize one of the
surprises that people don't realize that
costumes
bring to
an actor's
process
i feel like costumes kind of set an
atmosphere bringing into the world of of
what you're trying to create for example
for
bernardo's character there was this
element of
bringing out this classy side of him but
also bringing out this fighter side of
him this animalistic fighter side of him
and having for example the costumes and
dance at the gym completely different to
what bernard was also wearing during the
rumble and that kind of emphasizes the
drastic changes that bernardo goes
through internally so i think for
me each costume kind of
gives you an idea of what the scene and
the atmosphere of that scene is going to
be and you know the actor doesn't really
have to do that much work everything
around is is being done for you to be
able to step into the character and and
do what you have to do you know he has
kind of a sartorial sense about him you
know and a style about him that i think
is reflective of that world of boxing so
it was great to be able to
open that up a bit and give bernardo
some style i mean you you wore those
clothes very well
those high waist pants i love them i was
i was afraid of them at first but they
worked out
you know i i'd like to know how you
approached the costume designing for the
characters of this film and what were
your inspirations
i would say that you know i always start
uh you know with with the piece itself
uh and doing a lot of reading and then i
go directly to research you know and and
it
for this there was a lot of photographs
uh of the period different communities
in and around new york city
um that i was able to uh
tap into
uh even the the community of
the gangs you know and and you know what
would be reflective of the sharks and
the jets
uh so i collected as many images as i
could uh and
then you know presented those to stephen
and you know we had a lot of really
in-depth conversations you know specific
to the different characters and how he
saw the different characters
uh and and how they relate together
after i got
more information about what was going on
in his head and how he wanted to tell
the story of west side story went away
and came back with costume sketches that
were reflective of you know what his
ideas were for stephen it was how how
does he relate to clothing how does he
relate to these characters and the
clothing that i'm presenting to him is
there david one memory that you would
say
uh you know that sticks in your head
as far as
our experience together uh you know
working together costume designer to
actor
absolutely um i definitely have a couple
i i remember the first time i went to
to where you were working in the studio
and
i was able to see the sketches of what
we were going to be wearing i had no
idea what my character is going to be
wearing in the movie and working with
you and seeing these sketches and seeing
how it was all going to come together
that really is what started to spark my
ideas for bernardo and then i remember
also when we were shooting uh the whole
america sequence it was
just um
we were doing it during a major heat
wave
and i remember we had to like cancel two
of the shoots but i it was just crazy to
see all those costumes and all those
performers out there at 105 degree
weather dancing um it says a lot about
the costumes too at how comfortable it
was for the performers to wear because
that's the hard thing about costume
designing especially when you're making
a movie musical is that you have to find
this balance of realism but also comfort
for dancers to be able to move and and
flow in and i think i think you found
such an incredible
balance between realism and comfort for
for us dancers in the movie um yeah i
mean you know a lot of my focus is on
function and making sure that
performers can do everything they need
to do while still being reflective of
the characters it was so inspiring
though you know all of the the beautiful
energy and the fact that you guys always
hit your mark i mean it was just
breathtaking days you know to
be on set with you guys what's one thing
that people might be surprised
about costume designing
[Music]
it's not glamorous
but i don't know if anybody would be
surprised i think that uh the
thought process that goes into costumes
many people would be surprised
in making one choice it's informed by
the idea of what's come before it you
know what what what is the story that
has happened
before this moment that we're actually
uh designing for and how can
you know the choices that i make as a
costume designer underscore the
character's overall
story and then and then arc
within the within the film what
preparation came in for
for west side story and how were you
inspired by the original one when
costume designing for this one or were
you not thinking about the original a
huge amount of preparation went into uh
making you know developing the costume
design for west side story i already
knew the
original film and i knew the costume
design from the original broadway show
it was designed by the same person
originally and i i loved that design
when i was asked to
design west side story by steven
spielberg i found it really daunting to
think about
reconsidering re-envisioning
what that world might have been because
i felt like it was
perfect for that film but i needed to
set aside that idea so that i could
develop my own vision and have that
vision be reflective of what stephen was
asking for when when was it that you
knew
anita's dress was going to be yellow for
america
i uh and that's a big one you know and
that and that's directly reflective of
how i feel about the original design uh
by irene sheriff you know that purple
dress is so iconic and it's so iconic
for rita moreno i knew that i needed to
come up with a vision for ariana dubose
as anita
that would be just as iconic
and
so i was thinking about color i thought
i thought a lot about color and how that
uh would play a part and you know i was
also developing the color palette for
the the overall film
and when i decided that the sharks
would be reflective of where they had
come from be reflective of the latinx
communities that they migrated from you
know the the
the tropical uh color palette and style
and you know the the flower patterns and
you know the the more kind of
curvilinear organic quality that that
they carried with them i then knew that
whatever color i put anita in for that
number needs to feel very much at home
but also pull a lot of attention because
we were going to be in the you know in
the streets of new york surrounded by
buildings and surrounded by huge numbers
of people and you know i think that it
was very successful that you know you
you always can find her within
you know any of the spaces that you both
traveled in i'm so happy with that you
know how it turned out with reflecting
your love story you know that the
bernardo anita love story you become as
bernardo very heroic with your black and
red and and light pleated pants and then
she you know she's very much you know
just radiant underscoring this kind of a
vitality of spirit that she uh emanates
that worked out so
well uh within than everyone else and
and how you related to everyone else
yeah
i mean the costumes were beautiful and
it was such an honor to work with you
paul really thank you absolutely it was
a great honor to work with you david
[Music]
you